candidates vying for positions in the
August polls have filed their papers in
court including the incumbent president
Emerson Managua from Zimbabwe's
governing design repair party his party
has been in power for 43 years and
denies allegations made by the
opposition of systematically targeting
voices of dissent
this process is so peaceful this is what
we want we should continue
now during the possible campaigning
during the elections post-election this
is the peace we want is a mature
democracy was main opponent is
opposition neither Nelson Chamisa he
used to lead the movement for Democratic
change party until a Court ruling in
2020 stripped him of the leadership
last year he formed the citizens
Coalition for change party and he's
popular in cities the next header is the
issue of the voters from and the issue
of making sure that all those who
registered and participated in 2018 or
post 2018 as registered voters their
names have to be reflected the
information we have so far is that most
of the names are missing and would want
to understand why zimbabweans are
heading to the polls frustrated about
the economy and high unemployment the
cost of living crisis is a big issue
this election this country has one of
the highest inflation rates in the world
businesses are struggling to cope with
crippling power outages and an unstable
local currency
this will be the second time when
nangagwa and Chamisa face each other
both men say if they win they will
quickly turn around the economy promises
Zimbabwean said they're here every time
there's an election
haramutasa Al Jazeera Harare